maintenant je sais ce que je dois faire
confiance est plus gros que tu veux
faire je vais être un coût minime rallye
on m'a retrouvé la maison d'arthur
s'arrête là
pour demander l'aumône ya quelqu'un
sait pas exactement je cherche une
maison correspond elle parfume
ça me fait penser aux chiens autour de
la maison d'arthur du château à tout
prix
mes amis me régis train
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] c'est quoi ce bordel
moi je passais s'être au dessin
vient d'épouser campa dans cette fable
pour tous cas ce tissu
rue st
dix des dangereux
trois fois
puis un souci
on n'était pas là
rejoindre le monde des minimoys
si le moment
une épée
des toits
de fait
[Musique]